[Music]
we lost all of us
the lost friends
you're lost family today we have a
chance to take it all back
we will whatever it takes whatever it
takes
whatever it takes
I like this one
hi everyone is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of New Avengers footage to break
down and we got to talk about the Fox
Disney deal what's gonna be happening
with the x-men and the Fantastic Four
characters including Deadpool within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the next
couple of years so it is a really good
week to be a big Marvel fan Kevin Feige
is probably popping bottles all over the
Disney offices this week in honor of the
occasion will do a new round of the IMAX
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite x-men character on the video
for those of you asking about when
tickets will be on sale for Avengers and
game it'll probably be the first week in
April just like it was for infinity war
they haven't made any announcements yet
but when they do put tickets on sale
they'll be even more new footage that
they'll drop like here you go here's a
whole bunch of new footage now everybody
buy tickets to our movie whatever it
takes the funny thing about the new TV
spot too is that there's a couple shots
like when they do their slow-motion walk
where the characters are different in
the wide shot than they are in all the
up-close shots so I'll explain some of
the differences but it's mostly to honor
the fall like that's what they're
calling it the honor TV spot because
they start with the dusted Marvel
Studios 10-year anniversary logo this
version of the logo is probably going to
be in every single piece of footage that
they released for the movie it looks
really badass but it also reminds you
about everything that happened at the
end of infinity war they show a scene of
black panther in sharees lab during the
Black Panther movie they show a scene of
dr. strange inside the hospital during
the Doctor Strange movie when they were
in the middle of that hospital battle
there's a scene of wasp from Ant Man of
the wasp the scene of Captain America
and Bucky is from Captain America Civil
War the scene of the guardians is when
they're walking to meet ego the Living
Planet for the first time during
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 then
there's a scene of the Quinjet flying
over Tokyo this is probably when Black
Widow is going to pick up Hawkeye but
the thing about that is that when
they're standing in the rain and he's
got all those bodies around him that
he's just dropped with that samurai
sword and he's got his full Ronin
costume on and turns around and she has
the umbrella she has a lighter shade of
long blonde hair but then when they show
this scene of them on the back of this
ship it's actually the guardians of the
galaxy's benatar ship not the Quinn jet
and she's got her full-blown red hair
with like the one little strand of
blonde in it that we've seen from behind
the
like since the events of the snap she's
have been letting her red hair grow back
out so that's why it's mixed in with
some of the dyed blonde hair that she
had during infinity pour then there's a
slow-motion scene of Thor with
Stormbreaker just lifting it up he's
floating in the air you can tell because
his cape is billowing behind him so
whatever's happening in this scene is a
slow-motion Thor shot this scene of Iron
Man on the Benatar with his voiceover
from a different scene saying whatever
it takes looks like it's one of those
moments where he turns a corner like
he's been all depressed and he thinks
they're gonna die he's leaving his
message for pepper but then it winds up
being one of those call to action scenes
like during the cave in Iron Man 1 where
he starts macgyvering his way out of the
situation with nebula in the funny thing
about this last big slow motion hero
walk that they do is that if you look at
the wide shot the characters that are in
the wide shot are different than the
characters that you get in all the
close-ups taking it at face value
assuming that there aren't like any
secret characters in the background that
they photoshopped out its cap in front
than Iron Man right behind him Black
Widow right next to Iron Man then it's
nebula in ant-man in the close-up shots
but then if you look at the wide shot
it's actually rocket that's standing
next to Black Widow nebula is not in the
wide shot then behind them in the
close-up it's Hawkeye in war machine
Hawkeye is not in the wide shot next to
war machine in the wide one it's
actually banner in a suit that's behind
a war machine here not as the Hulk just
as banner or walking with them so this
is some trickery that's going on here or
these are from two completely different
scenes which i think is more likely so
it's a little too early to say that
there's gonna be time loops or they're
gonna try multiple different ways to fix
things but just keep in mind that
there's not going to be any one thing
that they do so the new synopsis
actually reads the grave course of
events set in motion by Thanos that
wiped out half the universe and
fractures the Avengers ranks compels the
remaining Avengers to take one final
stand in Marvel Studios grand conclusion
to 22 films Avengers endgame so the
synopsis says they're gonna take one
final stand but I think really what's
going on is is there'll be a couple
different types of attempts in a couple
different big battle scenes like the
same way that you got a couple really
big battles during Avengers infinity war
there was the battle at the beginning
with the sanctum then you had the Battle
of Wakanda you had the battle on Titan
so just think of
how big an epic Avengers endgame is
going to be so that means that you're
not gonna go for very long during the
movie without a big action set piece
like usually those demarcate the
different acts of the film like there's
a really big fight early on then there's
a big bite in the middle in a really big
bite at the end so just keep in mind
that even though they're telling you
they're gonna take one final stand there
will probably be multiple final stands
during the movie but now we got to talk
about the Fox Disney deal I know
everybody's wondering when are we gonna
start seeing x-men and Fantastic Four
characters Deadpool characters pop up in
Marvel films so as of yesterday Kevin
Feige was legally allowed to start
developing those movies those characters
think about putting them in other Marvel
films making solo x-men and Fantastic
Four films right after the deal
completed yesterday Disney updated their
masthead with all the big-box brands so
like you see the Simpsons on there
there's Deadpool James Cameron's Avatar
you've probably been seeing memes for
the last couple of days but unless
there's some major script rewrites for
the next few Marvel phase four films
they're gonna be shooting this year in
next year don't expect to see a whole
bunch of Marvel MCU x-men characters in
movies till at least 2021 as of right
now the movies that are coming out next
year are supposed to be the Black Widow
movie which as far as we've heard is
supposedly set during the past they've
already finished the eternal script as
well that movie's supposed to come out
at the end of next year but when all the
Hollywood trades are reporting that 2021
is the earliest where you would start
seeing x-men Fantastic Four characters
the movies that are on track to be
released that year are Doctor Strange 2
Black Panther 2 in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 right after those will
probably be shang-chi the next year 2022
because they just hired a director for
that but they haven't said a whole lot
about who else is gonna be in it but the
reason why 2021 is the earliest date is
because guardians of the galaxy vol 3 is
gonna be shot after James Gunn does
Suicide Squad 2 so even though he's
finished the script for guardians 3
there's still plenty of time for him to
swap a character out James Gunn is the
biggest comic book fanboy director that
Marvel has on their payroll he said many
times that he would love to include
x-men characters Fantastic Four
characters like Galactus in his
Guardians movies but at the time when he
was answering all those questions a
couple years ago when guardians 2 was
getting ready to come out he said it's
just you know not feasible we don't have
access
to those characters right now if he does
add any x-men or Fantastic Four
characters two Guardians three they
would probably be more cosmic characters
that have ties to the guardians of the
galaxy Doctor Strange to one of the
other movies that's coming out during
2021 is in the middle of being written
so there's still plenty of time to add
relevant characters to that story in
Ryan Coogler has just started writing
the script for Black Panther 2 that'll
probably shoot sometime next year -
plenty of time for him to add x-men
characters like Namor or whoever he
wants even as far back as the first
Black Panther film before he landed on
kill monger is the villain he wanted
Kraven the hunter to be the villain of
that movie and that's a Sony Marvel
character so he was already thinking
outside of the box when it came to
including other characters so the only
exception to all of the plans that are
happening with x-men and Fantastic Four
all the recasting which I'll talk about
in a second is Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
character and his franchise he's the
only person the only character who's
probably going to come over and continue
playing the character Disney has already
said that they'll continue to make
r-rated Deadpool films and now that Fox
is a brand within Disney just like Pixar
or Marvel Studios Fox will continue to
release films they will probably release
the r-rated films the Disney does not
want to release themselves we don't have
a timetable for when Deadpool 3 is going
to come out they're probably gonna
decide that sometime in the next couple
of months and Kevin Feige will just send
them off to do their own thing but like
I said Fox will probably handle that
film so it will not be part of the three
films per year that Marvel releases 2022
and Beyond is probably when we start
seeing solo Marvel Fantastic Four films
solo Marvel x-men franchises when they
reboot all those characters that'll give
him a three-year cooling-off period
after Fox's Dark Phoenix is released
this summer they're still releasing Dark
Phoenix this summer I know people were
wondering about that last year the one
movie that they are messing with is New
Mutants and they have a cut of it right
now they were supposed to be reshoots
those have not happened yet
right now the trades are reporting that
it's pretty likely Disney is just gonna
release that on their Disney Plus
streaming service at the end of this
year when it launches instead of
releasing New Mutants and theaters like
a traditional film pretty much
everybody's on the same page though that
it's going to be several years before
you see a giant
of brand-new Marvel x-men vs. Avengers
in a movie together but starting around
2021 is probably when you'll see x-men
characters piecemeal start popping up in
other people's films and they start
seeding the universe with those people
all kinds of theories about who would be
really cool villains for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Doctor Doom would be
a great Avengers level villain they
haven't given a date about when this
summer they're gonna announce their full
Marvel phase 4 movie schedule but most
of those films will be the ones that we
already know about so there won't be too
many really big surprises but probably a
couple usually when they make those
announcements they give key art concept
art or if there's a teaser that's
available they'll release some of that -
probably something for the Black Widow
movie when Marvel starts making more
official announcements and when we get
closer to Avengers endgame hitting
theaters all doom or Marvel phase four
videos but if there are any specific
questions or any videos that you want me
to make about those or the x-men or
Fantastic Four films just let me know in
the comments I'm also allowed to post my
Shazam review on Saturdays so look out
for that while you wait for that click
here for my breakdown of the alternate
version of The Avengers end game trailer
with different footage and click here to
re-watch the Avengers endgame trailer a
billion more times thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]